so we knew when we looked at the
proposal for Donald Trump's Republican
tax cut last year we knew from reading
it that it would increase the budget
deficit there are good and bad reasons
to deficit spend we've debated some of
those reasons before what we have almost
unanimous consent on is that deficit
spending to give tax cuts to the richest
Americans is not an economic
economically stimulative reason to go
into debt so we knew it would happen and
it has the deficit has exploded the
numbers show it we've covered it before
and so Donald Trump is now faced with
exploding budget deficits added to his
China tariffs which have so deeply hurt
farmers that the federal government is
now paying to bail them out as well just
racking up even more deficits again as a
result of the policies that Donald Trump
has chosen chosen to enact so what is it
that Republicans had Cruz is doing he's
demanding a tax cut for the rich
expedited without even getting
congressional approval Cruz sent a
letter to Treasury Secretary Stephen
minuchin asking that capital gains be
indexed to inflation now this requires
some explanation and I hope that I'm
gonna do a good job of this because
these things are not always the easiest
to explain to understand how this is a
tax cut for the rich you have to
understand how capital gains normally
work normally imagine that you buy a
thousand dollars worth of shares of
stock and those shares of stock go up in
value to five thousand dollars the
numbers are really clear you paid a
thousand it's worth worth five thousand
when you sell those shares you have four
thousand in gains and you pay capital
gains tax on the four thousand dollars
that's easy now to index capital gains
to inflation means that you add
inflation to the purchase price of a
thousand dollars so in our example
imagine that you paid the thousand
dollars for those shares five years ago
and in those five years there's been
enough inflation that a thousand dollars
then is like a thousand eighty one
dollars today that's what I got when I
use an inflation a calculator when you
index capita
gains to inflation you allow the cost
basis of those shares to be a thousand
eighty one dollars instead of a thousand
so what that means is instead of paying
capital gains taxes on that full four
thousand dollars you're only paying
capital gains on a little bit over
thirty nine hundred dollars now it
doesn't sound like much with those
numbers but that's what's important
about this this is a ton of money for
the very rich the reason that it is
effectively a tax cut for the rich is
that for most people indexing capital
gains to inflation is a difference of
just a few dollars here they're 86
percent of this action would go to the
top one percent okay understand the
scope of those numbers 86 percent of the
benefit of making capital gains indexed
to inflation would go to the top one
percent at a cost of more than 100
billion dollars over a decade meaning
even more debt which Donald from told us
he was going to eliminate the mere
suggestion that this is an emergency
requiring executive action is laughable
now this is one of those cases let me be
clear I would love this over time more
and more of my income has come from
capital gains of different kinds this is
a change that would be great for me but
it's an immoral change there is no
economically defensible rationale for
doing this at all never mind the
completely comical farcical assertion
that this is such an emergency that it
should be done by executive order rather
than by actually getting a bill through
Congress and signed into law in order to
do this which they probably wouldn't be
able to do because it is such a
capitalist handout the funniest or maybe
the saddest part about this is that Ted
Cruz is actually touting it as a way to
quote help everyday Americans 86% of the
benefit from this would go to the top
one percent the bottom 99 percent would
then split 14 percent of the benefit and
by the way I think if you looked at like
the bottom 90% they would get a small
portion of that 14 percent I assume the
lion's share of that
14% would go for those between the top
one percent and the top 10% and
meanwhile the minimum wage hasn't even
kept up with inflation okay
understand the sick hypocrisy and crony
bottom-feeding pond-scum nonsense of
this they say emergency we've got to
index capital gains to inflation
meanwhile the minimum wage hasn't kept
up with inflation the bottom half of
America hasn't seen in real terms wage
increase in decades or what is it 30 or
40 years that's not an emergency but
indexing capital gains to inflation is
such a problem such an emergency that
immediately we need to go outside of the
normal legislative process and get an
executive order in place these people
are immoral that's it I mean Ted Cruz
has to be voted out but Ted Cruz is just
a symptom of the disease it's way bigger
than Ted Cruz today's sponsor is
Skillshare and I'm excited to tell you
that everybody in our audience is
getting two entire months of free access
to Skillshare when you click the link
underneath this video skill shares the
site that offers over 25,000 online
courses on almost any topic you can
imagine cooking meditation photography
video editing Photoshop managing a small
business almost an endless list and
whether you're trying to get ahead in
your career maybe you want to learn new
skills that will make you better at your
job you might just be exploring a new
hobby and you're trying to find new ways
to be creative in your personal time
skill shares the perfect place to fully
immerse yourself in whatever you're
trying to learn I really enjoyed the
class on more advanced video editing
techniques because it's something I've
been wanting to improve at but have been
very busy hosting the david packard show
for the last few years
once again the david pakman show is
giving you two whole months of access to
every single class offered by Skillshare
after those two months if you want to
keep your subscription Skillshare super
affordable at less than ten bucks a
month get better at whatever it is that
you're
passionate about or discover something
brand-new that you didn't even know that
you would love and join skill shares
other 7 million users by clicking the
link underneath this video
[Music]